- Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is 'believe' and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your
journey today's message is,
"Go work at McDonald's".
Over to you Robert Kiyosaki.
(rooster crows) "♫ I
wake up every morning."
"♫ Espresso keep me going."
"♫ I wake up every morning."
- You wake up tomorrow morning
and you're on the street
and you have nothing.
You don't have a single
contact in your network.
All you have is the knowledge and
experience that you've had
throughout your career.
How do you build up from there?
- Well, I've been there, many times.
So, it's no big deal.
You just figure out what's needed
and wanted and you go do it.
People always kind of dump
on, what do you call it?
Fast food industry.
If I had to do it again,
I'd go work for McDonald's.
The reason I'd go work for
McDonald's, whether it's seven
bucks an hour or 50, I don't really care;
I don't really like
McDonald's food but they have
the best business systems in the world.
How else can a company take
virtually non-college educated
people and build a fast food
industry across the world?
And they have the best system,
so right inside that little
McDonald's you can learn
everything you need to
learn about business
except for the management side of it.
So, I'd just go work at McDonald's
so I could learn even more.
I look at life as learning.
I'm constantly learning.
You know, I'm reading
constantly, studying constantly.
I spend most of my time
with entrepreneurs.
I don't spend my time with people who
complain about the economy, you know.
So, nothing would really change.
I'd just go back to being an entrepreneur.
- If you want to learn
how to do something,
the fastest way to do it is to go work
for somebody who's already done it.
Now, I'm not as huge a
fan about working for
a giant corporation because
often you are assigned
a really specific task and
you don't really get to
explore quickly but if you
work for somebody who's
got a much smaller
company, an entrepreneur,
then you get to take on a
lot more responsibilities.
My idea is I would suggest
to go work for somebody
who has 10 employees or
less, who's doing exactly
what you want to do, and get as close to
the entrepreneur founder as possible.
You get hired to whatever job
it is that you want to learn.
Right?
But then you get as close to
the entrepreneur as possible,
take on more work, work
overtime, work extra hours
because this isn't work;
this is your education.
You're getting paid to
learn instead of paying
to go to a university you
are getting paid to make
mistakes, to learn how things
are done, to understanding
if this is even an industry
that you want to get into.
You're getting paid to learn.
And that's the best way
to go out and do it.
So, when I sold my first
business, as an example,
I wanted to learn about raising capital.
I wanted to learn that process.
I wanted to learn from
people who'd gone through it.
I didn't have to raise
money for my business;
we thought about it, we almost
did it but we got bought
before we needed to go and do it.
So after I sold my
company, I went to go work
at a venture capital company
and I connected with these VCs.
There were four of them
in their 60s or 70s.
They knew the street, they
had a wealth of experience
and education, and I helped
them bring in new leads.
In that process, I learned not just about
the raising capital industry,
the game, how it works,
what people look for, what it
all looks like because I had
zero concept, I never
needed it from my business;
but I also got to see how they operated,
how they thought about business,
the advice that they
gave the entrepreneur.
One of my favorite
experiences was we got hired
to basically be a temporary
chairman for a company,
to go in and advise the CEO of what to do.
Every month we'd go in
and look at the numbers
and have conversations and guide the CEO
to make better decisions in her business.
It was awesome.
It was awesome to see
how these guys thought.
A lot of what they learned
and taught I picked up,
right as the guys were doing
what I wanted to learn.
So it's the fastest way to learn.
Whatever it is that you want
to do, if you're uncertain,
if you need more education,
if you haven't committed
to getting going yet; go work
for somebody who's done it.
Model their success.
Again, first they'll
teach you if this is even
an industry you want to get into.
Sometimes you get into
something and you realize,
"you know what, I don't really like that,
I don't really want to do that" and better
to figure it out while working
for somebody else than to invest
your own time, money,
and resources into it.
And two, they'll shake out your path.
Instead of you failing and
struggling over and over
and over and over again, they'll teach you
how to do it a lot more quickly.
And then I'd also start
my thing on the side.
I'd be moonlighting, I'd
be working part-time,
I'd be finding a way to get my own
business up on the side.
But learning from somebody
who's already done
exactly what you want to do, I believe,
is one of the fastest ways to
get to where you want to go.
So the question made today
is I'm curious what is
one of the greatest lessons
that you have learned
from somebody else that
you've applied to your life
or to your business recently,
like in the past year?
The greatest lesson you've
learned in the past year
from somebody that's had
a big impact in your life
or your business leave it
down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to June Thomas.
June, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book "Your One Word".
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and remember; your one word is?
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
"♫ I wake up every morning."
"♫ Espresso keeps me going."
(typing)
- [Charles] When you cease
to learn, you cease to grow.
When you cease to learn, you sort of
begin to decay a little bit.
You are to learn how to stay healthy.
And you say, "Well, how do I do that?"
Well, the proper diet,
and exercise, and rest.
That's part of it.
In other words, we're
not healthy by accident.
It's by learning some key things in life
that really make a difference.
When we keep learning
something happens in our life.
For example, you and
I are living in an age
when we've had to keep learning.
Because when I was born there were
no computers that I knew of in 1932.
We go back and you look at your life
and think about all the things
that you've had to learn
that your predecessors
and your parents didn't
have to learn because
they didn't even exist.
If you're going to be useful
all the days of your life,
you've got to be willing to keep learning.
I would simply say that a
lazy brain is an aging brain.
You don't want to learn?
What happens; you start decaying.
There's something interesting and exciting
about learning things in life.
No matter who you are and no
matter what your age might be.
- Sometimes when it's all
about you, like I said,
never get high on your own supply, right?
When it's all about you, you
know like Biggie says actually,
or actually Scarface,
we'll go back all the way
to the original reference, but,
you can't think that you're
the only game in town.
That's a really dangerous
thought process, man.
Collaboration's good and it's healthy.
Working with young cats that are coming up
and have their own revenge fantasies?
Yeah, you could learn from that.
I'm not too old to learn, man.
I've been going to school
since; I might not have been
in the classroom but
school has come to me.
Like when you want to
learn, school comes to you.
- What is like the
number one thing to take
from the "Ego is the Enemy"
and a piece of advice
you would give to a young
Ryan Holiday who's now
19, 20 years old that's
watching this right now?
- Yeah so one of my favorite
sections of the book
is this idea that you can
never stop being a student.
Because students are humble
because they understand
that there's someone above
them who can teach them.
So you never stop being a student.
There's a quote from Epictetus that says,
"One cannot learn that which
they think they already know."
And so, if you think you
already know everything,
you've stopped being a student
and you're not going to learn anymore.
In some ways it's over for you.
I was forced to look at the world
the way he looks at the world.
Like how I researched books I
learned from Robert's system,
because as his research
assistant he wasn't like,
"Oh, go make up your own
system;" he was like,
"This is how I do it, you
need to do it this way
so you can be of service to me."
And so you're sort of
learning how to do that thing
rather than like sitting
down and reading a book
about it or trying to learn a song by ear.
It's like no, somebody showed
you how to do each step.